bonjour jean loubon amis merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur arte
souvent chaud pour cette journée
particulière
on l'a vu tout à l'heure quatre secondes
de poignées de main un petit sourire de
vladimir poutine à la presse léger
sourire également de joe biden sourires
de façade
comment est-ce que vous et analyser ce
protocole oblige et et bien oui là c'est
un comme pour reprendre votre expression
c'est un protocole qui est obligé il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il y a encore
quelques semaines
joe biden avait eu des mots très durs
contre vladimir poutine des mots qui là
ne correspondait pas forcément au
protocole il l'avait qualifié de tueur
et donc justement là il ya une tentative
de rapprochement qui répond aux usages
protocolaires en vigueur et je pense on
va y revenir mais que joe biden hésite
entre deux options concernant la russie
joe biden qui a déclaré à ce moment là
c'est quand même mieux de se voir en
tête à tête
de son côté vladimir poutine lui a
déclaré au président américain
espéraient une rencontre productive
pareil comment est-ce qu'il faut
analyser ces deux premières prises de
parole alors plusieurs choses
premièrement on parle beaucoup de qui
monsieur buydens rencontre c'est à dire
il rencontre vladimir poutine et c'est
un événement mais on devrait aussi
parler de qui ils ne rencontrent pas en
tête à tête
en effet joe biden a rencontré en tête à
tête boris johnson le premier ministre
britannique
l'homme du breakbeat il a rencontré en
tête à tête la reine d'angleterre
elizabeth ii et le président turc
erdogan pour finir par cette rencontre
au sommet tant attendu avec vladimir
poutine
mais comme le soulignait d'autres
analystes il n'a rencontré ni emmanuel
macron en tête à tête ni aucun
représentant des instances de l'union
européenne que ce soit
charles michel ou madame von der leyen
donc je pense que c'est à noter joe
biden
entre ici le peu de cas qu'il fait de
l'union européenne qu'ils considèrent
comme une grande machine technocratique
sans puissance et il montre que ce qui
compte pour lui ce sont les nations
souveraines
le royaume uni qui reconquiert sa
souveraineté la turquie qui s'affirme
la russie est donc pour joe biden qui
est lui même à la tête d'une nation
souveraine ce qui compte c'est la
souveraineté et non pas une union
européenne qui apparaît comme faibles
technocratique et divisé bonjour je me
permets de vous couper parce que vous
par l'union européenne avant cette
rencontre l'union européenne à
distribuer des sanctions contre la
biélorussie nouveau train de sanctions
avec 78 ans et cette entité a ajouté par
bruxelles dans la liste des personnes
accusées par lieu de réprimer
l'opposition à minsk
quid du timing de cette
de cette annonce de la part de l'union
européenne parce que ça peut jouer dans
les négociations liées alors je ne sais
pas si ça si ça jouera dans les
négociations de cet après midi qui
seront peut-être plus plus générale mais
en tout cas c'est sûr que l'union
européenne continue sur une ligne qui
est globalement hostile à la russie et à
la biélorussie qui est perçu comme un
allié comme un client de la russie
mais en ce qui concerne la rencontre
bayonne
poutine ce qui compte avant tout pour
joe biden c'est qu'il est entré dans une
nouvelle guerre froide contre la chine
et qu'il veut un maximum d'allier donc
dans un premier temps il a battu le
rappel des alliés de l'otan un dans son
discours a le temps il a évoqué la
menace chinoise et c'est la première
fois qu'un président américain fait
mention de la menace chinoise dans un
discours auprès de l'otan puisque à la
base le temps c'est l'organisation de
l'atlantique nord donc ça n'a
normalement rien à voir avec les films
c'est une organisation qui est dirigé
contre la russie et qui n'a rien à voir
ni de près ni de loin avec la chine ce
que veut faire joe biden s'est
réorientée l'otan dans un sens anti
chinois pour servir les états unis dans
leur nouvelle guerre froide contre la
chine
et ensuite dans un second temps il y a
éventuellement une tentative de détente
pour reprendre ce terme de la guerre
froide avec la russie de façon à ne pas
complètement jeté la russie dans les
bras de la chine pense qu'aujourd'hui
joe biden est tiraillé entre deux
options première option
une nouvelle guerre froide contre la
russie et la chine
c'est à dire d'affronter deux
adversaires coalisés exactement comme
les puissances occidentales durant la
première guerre mondiale avaient
affronté la coalition de l'environnement
et de l' empire austro-hongrois
je pense que cette ligne peut plaire à
beaucoup de gens aux états unis vous
c'est dans l'élite américaine ya quand
même le souvenir de 40-50 guerre froide
un lobby polono lituanien très hostile à
la russie est très influent aux états
unis
des défenseurs de droits de l'homme des
droits de l'homme très méfiant vis-à-vis
de la russie
donc cette ligne à la fois anti
chinoises et anti-russe peut faire
plaisir à un certain nombre de personnes
aux états unis et il ya une deuxième
ligne plus réaliste qui selon moi est
celle du bon sens de se dire que la
chine ait vraiment un adversaire
redoutable et qu'on ne peut pas lui
faire le cadeau de lui jeter la russie
dans les bras et qu'il faut instaurer
une ligne de détente pour ramener la
russie dans la famille occidentale à
laquelle elle appartient par sa culture
et pour la détacher de la chine
mais c'est sûr que si on a une attitude
très hostile à la russie qu'on multiplie
les sanctions eh bien on ne fait que la
jeter dans les bras de la chine donc je
pense que joe biden hésite entre ces
deux lignes soit se rapprocher des de la
russie pour faire face à la chine soit
entamé une guerre contre deux
adversaires coalisés russie et chine l'a
visiblement et que ce sommet ils optent
pour l'option du au moins provisoirement
du rapprochement avec la russie
merci jean loubon amis pour toutes ces
analyses et se tait cryptage rappelle
que vous êtes spécialiste en
géopolitique et en philosophie politique